we're here with the contributing editor
of one of my favorite magazines on
planet earth house beautiful and founder
of kingston design connection interior
designer marilyn demour
all right we can help the viewer
on their dining room yes i did to great
success in my opinion
um and we have an audience member who
has a little design dilemma in a special
drew and a where is tamara lynch
right here hello
hi um
my flower sees your flower i am a
passionate flower lover so i am so happy
to be here with you
what is your design question so
everybody knows so um i have this sofa
um i've had her for over 12 years and if
you sit in my couch you sink into it
um what's significant about this couch
you know people will be like oh just
throw it away and get a new one um
it's not that easy you know i lost my
job to the uh pandemic i worked as a
restaurant worker
um and then was basically told to sit
down on march 16th
2020 and when my job came back we only
took 25 of the workforce
so it was a different life for me um i
spent a lot of time depressed on this
couch but i've always been a resilient
person
and i just feel like
putting one foot in front of the other
is just even when you can't see where
you're going
you just do it and while i was on that
crowd
i did something watching your show
um which was just go online and say
put my head my name in a and i just like
a random
place and to be given a a gift like just
for your phone to ring and say hi
i have a random act of kindness for you
has been um
just
like it's just profound
profound it has been
i love your attitude of putting one foot
in front of the other your
sentimentality towards this couch is
completely understandable but telling
your story for me is the key so thank
you so much for sharing
and it's not trivial to pivot to the
couch i'm lucky that we are here with
one of my design heroes
i would love to know especially with
that beautiful backstory
now what marilyn yeah no so i really
really wanted to honor your sofa i love
that it's a part of your family and so
one of the first things i did was to
cover it in one of the most hard-wearing
fabrics out there which is linen so
linen will last you for many many years
to come
and then there are some colorful pillows
on top
and the other thing is you didn't
previously have a carpet
and i know in smaller spaces people tend
to think of adding less but really
defining a space
it's kind of counterintuitive but it
actually helps to give you the look and
feel of a bigger space and it defines
this as a real living room so bringing
that carpet is in is really important
the other thing that you didn't have was
a sofa
sorry a coffee table so the coffee table
is important because it just makes the
space more functional and you can
actually find these sometimes with
shelves it gives you a little bit more
storage so i brought that in as well
and overall you know the idea is to
really honor your living room to make it
a place that you can continue to add to
over the years so you can imagine a
brightly covered throw
more flowers some artwork but you know
the sofa will really become kind of the
anchor of your space
thank you that's beautiful
what do you think tamara i i that's
gorgeous
do you like it that's really beautiful i
just love the coolness of it that that
is beautiful
i thank you love it and you're
absolutely right the more you add into a
small space the bigger it seems it's
counterintuitive indeed but it's true
pack it i love it i hope you do too yeah
i do i think it's so sophisticated all
right well
thank god because it's all going home
with you every single thing in this room
we are putting
in your living room the coffee table the
couch the pillows the throws everything
and we have two thousand dollars for you
to do whatever you want with and then
i'm gonna match it so that's four oh my
god and let's just round it off to five
there's just five for you to
do with it as you see fit to make your
home life
um a little bit brighter
and i thank you so much
[Applause]
and marilyn thank you as always so much
you're just so
amazing oh thank you
[Music]